- I'm about to take the Disney Lyrics quiz
and I'm gonna be terrible at this.
- I'm really good at Disney songs from
or Disney lyrics from the 80's and 90's,
most of the 90's.
- I'm a reasonably big Disney fan
but I feel like I really know
like one song per movie maybe.
- I know the songs, I just don't think
I know the lyrics and I just kind of
sing them in my own way in the shower.
Let's do it.
I don't even remember
this part of the song.
- Staring at me?
- Stare at me?
- Staring's creepy so
it's probably looking.
Although that's a creepy ass
movie so it could be staring.
It's smiling, okay.
- I was close.
- It's creepy to stare at someone,
it's not creepy to smile at them.
- I guess that would make sense.
- Smile too hard, it's still creepy.
- All right so oh for one.
- Oh I don't know this move at all.
- Oh I never saw this movie.
- Coming on me?
- What does a summer breeze do to you?
- Blowing on me?
- Lifting me, I'm gonna say lifting.
- Calling me, yeah?
Get out.
- Calling me, damn.
- I was close, I said coming.
- All right, so one for two.
- Oh okay, Belle, I know her.
- Who's a man?
- Hold my hand?
- Like I planned?
- Why are these the
hardest parts of the song?
- Okay I'm just gonna,
someone who says I can.
- To have someone understand.
- Oh understand, I was close.
- I didn't actually know that, I just...
- I know what she wants, I
just don't know what she says.
- So misunderstood, poor Belle.
- I've got one.
- Oh Moana, I think I know this one.
- Oh, I didn't see Moana.
- Oh no, I haven't even seen this movie.
- Nope, I don't know this one.
- That's way confusing,
I would never want to
take directions from Moana.
- It's another one where
I'm just gonna have
to logic my way through songwriting.
- Belong?
sort of has an end rhyme.
- Stand?
- Uh, I guess that makes sense,
she is the female heroine,
she should be going
and doing all those things alone.
- Where I go alone?
I keep forgetting that rhyme,
I end rhymed the wrong part of the lyrics.
- See I'm going for like one word here
and it's like, I've
heard two words or three.
- Man, that's hard.
- Is it Grandma?
Isn't she singing to her
dead Grandma spirits?
- There's an eagle in
the background, Jesus.
- Oh I knew it, eagle and mountain.
- Ah yeah, I should have
picked landscape things.
- Wow I feel like a terrible 90's kid.
- Could it be, no escape
from the cool inside of me?
Because she's got this coldness going on
that's making her freeze.
- Cold, cold, she's dead inside, like me.
She's cold and dead inside.
- No escape from the cold inside me?
- Ahh.
- It makes so much sense if it was cold.
She's literally frozen.
So me and Kelsey are tied for one for six.
- I said I was gonna be bad at this.
And like, always I didn't
surprise myself whatsoever.
- Usually the real answer is a lot better
than whatever I came up with.
- Probably should have my
Disney season pass revoked.
- But it's making me like,
remember, I need to see Moana.
- I need to go re-watch all of these.
- I'm gonna have to go home
and watch all of these movies.
- I should watch Tangled again,
it was pretty good.
- Maybe we should just watch
them all together this weekend.